Should I continue to do thermography?
So I don't know who was asked this question, but yes,
if you are doing if you've done the thermography for breast exam,
I was assuming this person has done thermography for breast exams in the past.
Maybe got a positive fighting and then maybe went the medical route, had it go again a biopsy, blah, blah, blah.
Now they're under care for cancer for breast cancer.
Should you continue to do thermography?
I think highly advisable to continue to do thermography because it can be a very simple,
not invasive screening tool moving forward.
Now there may be some some artifacts left over from, let's say the biopsy.
So you had this in the incision and blah, blah, blah.
You take that into account when you read the thermography.
But yes, continue to do thermography.
It's a great screening tool to screen progress as well.
So answer yes.